it's getting to be time for all media
across party lines across platforms to
unite to protect themselves from Donald
Trump who is waging a never-ending
increasingly disturbing war on the media
I told you last week that the Trump
administration has launched some major
attacks on freedom of press calling the
media the enemy of the American people
talking about journalism licenses
opening up libel laws to make it easier
to sue media outlets they banned CNN
reporter Caitlin Collins from a Rose
Garden press conference for some
questions she had asked they've been
pushing this outrageously partial push
poll to turn people even more strongly
against the media and now Donald Trump
went on if this isn't even the first
Sunday Twitter tirade that we're talking
about today but he went on a Sunday
Twitter tirade against what he calls the
very unpatriotic media why is the media
unpatriotic according to Trump because
they report what government does he
specifically calls out the New York
Times and The Washington Post who by the
way have done really great investigative
reporting on the Trump administration
this is what dictators do directly
attacking the press that holds them
accountable or at least tries to hold
them accountable and Donald Trump
tweeting when the media driven insane by
their Trump derangement syndrome reveals
internal deliberations of our government
it truly puts the lives of many not just
journalists at risk very unpatriotic
Freema freedom of the press also comes
with a responsibility to report the news
accurately 90% of media coverage of my
administration is negative despite the
tremendously positive results we are
achieving it's no surprise that
confidence in the media is at an
all-time low I will not allow our great
country to be sold out by anti Trump
haters in the dying newspaper industry
no matter how much they try to distract
and cover it up our country is making
great progress under my leadership and I
will never stop fighting for the
American people as an example the
failing New York Times and the Amazon
Washington Post do nothing but write bad
stories even on positive achievements
they will never change it's quite a
mouthful
90% actually sounds low like I can think
of three to four things Trump has done
that makes sense and some of those might
even have been done by
accident if 10% of coverage of Trump
were positive it would actually be too
high
given what Donald Trump is actually done
because this is an administration that's
a total and utter sham and what he's
trying to do is something that's not
that uncommon for the right which is
they want to get a monopoly on
patriotism it's another sign of
authoritarianism being the arbiters the
gatekeepers of what's patriotic and
what's not patriotic and it was also
revealed yesterday interestingly the
Donald Trump had a meeting with the New
York Times publisher AG salts burger and
talked about how he thinks the media is
the enemy of the people and sults burger
reportedly warned Trump and said you
know it's kind of a dangerous thing for
you to be doing that and yes it's
dangerous to the foundational tenets of
our country PR wise I don't know that
it's that dangerous for Trump to call
the media the enemy of the American
people because he's having some success
turning his base against a Free Press
yeah it is really working for him and
that's why fewer and fewer Americans
support like the robert muller
investigation him his poll numbers are
going up too I just think it's
completely unfounded like it's not the
media's job to be patriotic it's the
media's job to tell the truth and to be
objective and you know they were gonna
be patriotic we would have state-run
media which that's a great point which
is layer one is if you're going to
attribute patriotism to the media I
argue that
discussing and exposing what our
government does is a patriotic right
because it aligns with what the sort of
foundational tenets of our country are
but there's another side to it which is
media should not be making decisions on
the basis of patriotism they should be
making decisions on the basis of their
duty to report what it is that's going
on and and it's almost like irrelevant
whether we attribute patriotism to the
media yeah I mean you'd see that maybe
in North Korea or Russia are but
hopefully not in the United States the
most patriotic act you can do as a media
outlet is to report on what is happening
and what the government does is part of
that and of course Trump claimed to be a
fan of transparency during the campaign
seems almost hypocritical that now he
thinks reporting on what the government
does is bad but that being said as I
mentioned earlier Paul Manafort
trial starts tomorrow it's very clear
Michael Cohen is about to give up the
really good goods Trump's own CFO from
the Trump Organization might be
called to testify under oath the guys
probably panicking and that relates to
why he's going on multiple totally
outrageous hyperbolic apoplectic Twitter
rants on Sunday over the weekend
I am thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
asam / Pakman blink astiz a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka steaks the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a 7 day
free trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube
i've put a link in the description i
have listened to blinka spokes about
economics about political science about
history about science so many
interesting things and after the free
trial if you like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink accom slash Pakman that's bli
nki st.com /p a que ma n